good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller
and the scp we're going to be looking at
today is scp-1237
object class
ketter
special containment procedures due to
its pandemic and incorporeal nature
scp-1237 cannot be contained in a
traditional sense containment of
scp-1237 at this time shall be focused
on information management and on
identification and containment of
scp-1237-1
positive individuals
any non-foundation scientific research
which could lead to discovery of
scp-1237
is to be suppressed by any means
necessary conscription of researchers
involved in such studies as foundation
personnel or as d-class is authorized
the foundation is to sponsor efforts
wherever and whenever possible to
promote widespread dna testing of
civilians for the purpose of identifying
scp-12371
positives including but not limited to
mandatory testing
and other convicted offenders dna
testing as prerequisites for employment
or insurance eligibility dna
fingerprinting as a means of
identification universal prenatal
screenings and home dna testing kits
ostensibly for the purpose of
determining a person's ancestry
all foundation personnel and any
civilian who is allowed to know of the
foundation's existence
must be tested immediately
information is to be disseminated in the
medical community to the effect that an
scp-1230
result in a prenatal screening
is evidence of a deformative condition
with low viability and extreme health
risk to the mother and doctors are
advised to recommend that such
pregnancies be terminated if a known
scp-1237-1 positive pregnancy is not
voluntarily
induction of involuntary
is authorized
the foundation is to sponsor any and all
organizations or charities providing
prenatal screening and
services whether legal or not in
developing countries where these
services do not exist if these efforts
are unsuccessful sponsorship of
organizations participating in campaigns
of involuntary sterilization ethnic
cleansing or genocide is authorized
against populations with statistically
high rates of scp-1237-1
any person presenting at hospital or
police or otherwise identified as having
experienced an scp-1237 event is to be
detained for study and testing if the
individual is
scp-1237-1 negative they are to be
debriefed administered class b amnestic
and released
any person found to be
scp-12371-positive
or to have caused an scp-1237 incident
is to be detained immediately for study
and debriefing after debriefing they are
to be administered class omega amnestic
and detained indefinitely positives are
to be regularly dosed with class c
amnestics to prevent any development of
new memories regarding the existence of
the foundation
or any staff handling them
benzodiazepines to minimize slow wave
sleep and
to prevent rem sleep and during sleep
shall be monitored at all times by eeg
in the event that any positive enters an
scp-1237 state during observation they
are to be terminated immediately
if any scp-1237-1l
is identified by the foundation
authorization is granted to employ them
once and only once to attempt to
neutralize a kenner-class scp object
at the discretion of o5 after said
attempt whether successful or not
subject is to be terminated immediately
if any high profile person or public
place is affected by an scp-1237 event
the foundation is authorized to take
whatever steps necessary to prevent
public knowledge of this change up to
and including termination or complete
destruction of the person or place so
affected
description
scp-1237 is a state of electrical
activity in the human brain a brainwave
in common terminology observed in
certain individuals during periods of
extremely deep sleep this state
informally dubbed level 5 sleep or
epsilon wave sleep is profoundly
difficult to awaken the subject from
prior to adoption of current containment
protocols experiments with loud noise
bright lights chemical injections
electrical stimulation oxygen
deprivation physical injury and
mutilation and
all failed to arouse the subject the
ability to exhibit
scp-1237 is controlled by a gene
designated scp-1237-1
scp-1237-1 is present in approximately
zero point
percent of the total world population
however this number is as high as one
point percent among
and
ethnic groups
percent of scp-1237
positives experience at least one
scp-1237 event in their lives
percent experience two or more the
majority of scp-1237 events occur when
the subject is in their late teens to
early 30s
whereas
scp-1237-1 negative individuals do not
exhibit rem activity during the deepest
stages of sleep
scp-1237-1 positives do dreams
experienced during an scp-1237 event are
not of a significantly different nature
than dreams experienced by negatives
they may involve the dreamer
participating in routine daily
activities
find them in impossible or illogical
situations where people they may or may
not know behave uncharacteristically
or find them in scenarios most people
would find terrifying as with ordinary
dreams the subject has no apparent
control over the setting or events of
the dream or their actions therein when
dreaming during an scp-1237 state
however the brainwaves responsible for
rem activity and
scp-1237 activity
interact to produce a reality altering
effect
after an scp-1237 event occurs any
physical or mental changes that occur to
the subject in the dream will occur to
their waking form as well if the dream
involves persons or places that the
subject has personally interacted with
or visited those persons and places will
be altered as well in accordance with
the nature of the dream imaginary
persons or places or persons or places
not personally known by the subject are
not affected transformation is
instantaneous in all cases that have
been observed in general memories of
people not involved in the dream are
unaffected people encountering persons
affected by an scp-1237 event will
believe that the changes are correct and
that the person has always been that way
however they will have memories that
this is not the case attempts to
reconcile this among witnesses to an
scp-1237 event tend to result in chronic
uneasiness paranoia and
documented effects of scp-1237 events
have included
loss of limbs and organs or spontaneous
regeneration of limbs and organs
previously lost
complete and total changes in physical
appearance gender personality memories
age or species
acquisition of superhuman abilities
including the ability to fly lift
extremely heavy objects survive without
oxygen or see through solid objects
significant changes in the architecture
and floor plan of buildings of the
layout of city streets or of the
appearance characteristics or names of
landmarks
changes in the outcome of historical
events the subject was involved in
individuals returning to life several
years after dying
the spontaneous transformation of
national governments from one form to
another for example from a republic to a
constitutional monarchy or from a
democratic confederation to an
autocratic dictatorship
a very small percentage of
scp-1237-1 positives
believed to be in single digits
worldwide designated scp-1237-1-l
are capable of lucid dreaming the
ability to control the nature of their
dreams including those occurring in
scp-1237 events to date only one
scp-1237-1l has been identified by the
foundation see experiment log
t98816
oc108682 for details pertaining to its
disposition
addendum
note from senior researchers
it is of the utmost importance that all
agents assigned to scp-1237 containment
understand exactly how dangerous this
phenomenon can potentially become
we have no idea how much of our world
has been changed by these dreamers in
the past a single positive having a
single dream has the potential to change
the world for the worse what if a
mortician watches a scary movie then
falls asleep and dreams their town as
part of a zombie apocalypse what if a
globetrotter dreams about the end of the
world what if someone aware of our
existence dreams of a world where
there's no such thing as the foundation
we're talking ck maybe even xk level
events here as it stands right now we
don't even know how many of these people
are out there that we haven't found
for this reason i want to stress that
any means necessary to implement
universal dna testing and to remove
these people from the gene pool is
authorized and that there is absolutely
no margin of error for mercy
when you became part of this
organization you understood that we
sometimes have to do horrible things in
the name of the greater good things that
make it hard to sleep at night i must
ask you to do those horrible things and
continue doing those horrible things for
as long as it takes to neutralize this
threat
because it only takes one positive who
can sleep at night to create a world
where the rest of us will never wake up
again
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening
if indeed you still are
and you're all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
jos truvoca
professor puffer
retalias
jk
segnar
your local fishman derivative
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy
a real american hebrew
hms lily
the almighty fish
scio dio demnatus
eric corbige
longinus
the morrigan
caramel ashmuy
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you